passau a city located where two major
rivers merge and now experiencing its
worst flood disaster in centuries the
waters have begun receding leaving
behind debris and mud but residents are
cleaning up and determined to get back
to life as normal
rubber boots are essential equipment
here helpers have to trudge through
water and mud those without boots create
makeshift ones this volunteer has turned
a sturdy plastic bag into protective
gear she says all you need to do is tie
it around your foot and then around your
leg and that'll keep the mud out w ZN
and then and buying not my own oh my
mother special on the spanish club I
asked if it works he says yesterday it
held for three or four hours but today
he's tied the bags a little tighter at
this office at pasar University Carolina
oberlander is coordinating student
volunteer efforts the students are
organized and doing what they can it's
nice she says that pass our residents
see that we're not all lazy students we
also roll up our sleeves we're residents
too we want life to get back to normal
students have proven ready to lend a
hand two to three thousand are helping
out every day in passau
one of the volunteers sent to the banks
of the in river is Barbara graph who's
studying to become a teacher as a mirror
doesn't we're lucky our own living
quarters aren't affected she says now
that the water is gone it's unbelievable
how wrecked and full of mud everything
is but it's uplifting to see everyone
helping out but passau isn't free of the
flood waters just yet as I see when I
join or ities on patrol normally you
will be able to stroll along this
promenade here now you couldn't even
stand on the spot bastian bhava is
incredulous
arrogant he says it's shocking what
nature is capable of when you realize
how vulnerable you are in spite of
Technology and flood defenses there's
been a lot of investment here but in the
end mother nature was a meter higher
than expected pass our location means
it's prone to flooding but never before
has it been this bad the water has even
crept up to places previously considered
safe that's been the case for Vanek
house he wants to get into his apartment
and see just how bad it is but he can't
access it yet those videos in Augusta
you can't even see the house he says
it's located down a side street almost
the last house before the spot where the
inn and Danube meet
he waves over the water police but they
can't dock the mud underneath is too
deep and currents are dangerous the most
direct way is blocked by piles of sand
and mud floor student and Gillick akarma
ought to be studying for her bar exams
but she says there are more important
things at the moment they've been
wheeling one load of mud after another
out of flooded businesses she says the
disaster is weighing on everyone's minds
Vanek house and his wife Hannah cuts are
worried about their home but they're
trying to look on the bright side
disasters always have a positive side
Hannah says when people show solidarity
and stand together that goes a little
way towards helping reduce the
devastation Barbara graph and other
student volunteers have been assigned to
help clean out this bar that was
completely submerged all that's left is
mud and it's everywhere
the owner Rowell cuca hadn't even been
in business for a year when the flood
struck
so everyone get back a firefighter once
told him you have to fight water with
water the worst part the mud is best
cleared with more water the bar was his
hope for the future he invested all his
savings and took out a loan beneful
started he says without government
assistance he won't be able to pay back
the money he still owes the bank a
normal salary wouldn't be enough without
help he says he'll be ruined for the
next 10 years as I'm Anthony 15-yard I
led the 28 year old doesn't even want to
think about that prospect right now at
the moment he says he's just grateful
that he's not left all alone with the
cleanup work student volunteer Barbara
says passau is tight knit studying here
and taking advantage of the city's
offerings it's only right to show
solidarity and help out Vanek house and
his wife Hunnicutt's want to take stock
and get to work they're still hopeful of
getting a ride from the water police but
they're told the mud is nearly 2 meters
deep to the couple's disbelief the
authorities say it could take another
two days until they're able to reach
their home vaniqa says apparently it's
impossible until the mutt has been
cleared all one meter and 80 centimeters
of it
the couple are now afraid that their
house could be covered in mud too vanna
says that the houses further down
towards the river were built for floods
with living quarters elevated above
ground level but their's is not they
never thought that water could rise so
high so fast they simply weren't
prepared sandbags weren't enough to hold
back the water with flood levels
reaching a peak of 12 meters 80 back at
the University Catalina uber lender is
taking calls coming in by the minute via
the emergency hotline or she asks what
people need pass our residents have also
been using Facebook to announce what
help they're looking for or are in a
position to give how Alina says a
student just called to ask for help for
an elderly neighbor who's lost
everything five volunteers are being
dispatched to help her gather her
belongings and to calm her nerves the
students crisis response has proven
effective
they've even put together care packages
with food for the volunteers
I don't students say they packed cheese
and sausage sandwiches fruit and sweets
and that it's hopefully enough for the
aid workers the food has been donated by
passel businesses the care packages are
distributed to cruise in the city center
a firefighter expresses surprised at the
quality of the students goodies and adds
that everyone's thankful for them even
the helpers say thanks in Paso and this
even dessert ice cream vendor tit siano
Damiano is giving out free chocolate ice
cream to volunteers I Springs he says
ice cream makes people happy especially
chocolate flavor it boosts hormone
levels and makes you smile that way
people's faces shine again like the Sun
people are happy when they can eat ice
cream and there's no more rain of a
passel anymore they're egging me on
basil ice cream always helps water
police continue to patrol and currents
remain dangerous bastian bhava has been
a member of the volunteer water police
brigade for 20 years and this is his
first major test
was macht I devil's bath it's fun to
help he says and you gain useful
experience he says it's a good way to
spend his leisure time another reason
everyone's eager to help is that paso
depends on tourism and it's hoped that
visitors will want to return soon Hanna
cats wants to get into her home at last
she asks if this is the way her husband
has already managed to gain entry
supposedly by passing through this house
she can't believe the scenes around her
the water is waist high but luckily she
gets some assistance and she's grateful
for it it's unbelievable she says
finally she reaches her address hello
the floors are bending she exclaims
again she simply can't comprehend how
high the waters were but she's relieved
that all of her patient files in
cabinets above are secure she has a
psychiatry practice upstairs the floor
is ruined but at least her files have
been spared rands offer the damage could
have been worse there by having the
couple were evacuated from this balcony
several days ago emergency crews rescued
them with large boats once the water
reached dangerous levels now many in
passau are wondering how much their
insurance will cover
this school gym should be usable again
in a matter of days but first some 35
centimeters of mud have to be cleared
Barbara calf is one of the volunteers
it's a different job this time she says
it's hard work but not impossible you
stay busy building custodian vana Gaia
is coordinating the 30 volunteer helpers
in his gym as a passel native he's lived
through a number of floods this one he
says has overwhelmed him Passau hasn't
experienced a flood like this in 500
years but a robust community spirit has
also risen to the challenge